Bulgarien ist einer jener Länder die
immer in irgendeinem Drama stecken und
bei denen man nie weiß was als Nächstes
schief gehen könnte das süd-europäische
Land am Schwarzen Meer mit seiner rund 7
Millionen Einwohnern scheint ist immer
irgendwie wissen zu wollen damit ihr
euch ein Bild machen könnt wir reden
über ein Land in dem in der politischen
Arena eine riesiges Chaos herrscht
dieses Jahr werden sie jetzt im April
ihre fünfte Parlamentswahl in nur zwei
Jahren abhalten ja in der Tat 5
Neuwahlen in nur zwei Jahren und die
letzte fand übrigens gerade mal im
Oktober statt im Vergleich zu diesem
Balkan dann sind selbst Italien Japan
und sogar Israel praktisch Lehrlinge in
dieser besonderen Kunst des politischen
Chaos aber natürlich ist das nicht das
ganze Ausmaß des bulgarischen Dramas es
mag euch vielleicht überraschen aber
Bulgarien leidet auch an einem schweren
Fall von sagen wir geistiger Vernebelung
wenn es darum geht seine Beziehungen mit
dem besten und mit Russland
auszubalancieren
[Musik]
noch unmittelbar vor dem russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine hielt der
durchschnittliche IWA normalbulgare sehr
viel vom russischen Diktator Vladimir
Putin den meisten Bulgaren war es egal
dass der Tyrann bereits 2014 die Creme
annektiert hatte oder dass er es gewohnt
ist die elementassten Menschenrechte zu
verletzen so hatten 70% der Bulgaren im
Jahr 2021 eine positive Meinung von
Putin und 45% betrachteten Russland also
wichtigen strategischen Partner
[Musik]
und das ist schon etwas merkwürdig wenn
ich gar ein starker Widerspruch wenn man
bedenkt dass Bulgarien seit 2007
Mitglieder der Europäischen Union und
seit 2004 Mitglieder NATO ist rein
theoretisch könnte man also sagen dass
Bulgarien vollständig in das westliche
Lager integriert ist und nicht mehr
immer russischen Einflussbereich liegt
doch wie Ihr sehen werde zeichnet die
Realität ein viel komplexeres Bild das
nicht nur in Bulgarien anzutreffen ist
sondern in vielen anderen Ländern auch
in Ungarn und das Slowakei zum Beispiel
oder auch in der Schweiz Österreich und
Deutschland vor allem aber nicht nur in
den östlichen Bundesländern und aus
diesem Grund wollen wir dieses nicht zu
vernachlässigen Phänomene in diesem
Video am Beispiel einer sehr
interessanten Geschichte analysiert eine
Geschichte die manche von euch
vielleicht kurz in den Nachrichten
mitbekommen haben darin geht es um die
schnelle und kritische Waffenhilfe aus
Bulgarien wie der Ukraine gleich nach
dem russischen Einfall gewaltig aus der
Patsche erhalten aber wartet auf den
Plot fest denn diese Hilfe musste vor
der bulgarischen Regierung vor der
eigenen Bevölkerung und sogar vor dem
Koalitionspartner geheim gehalten werden
also lasst uns auf den Ball kein reisen
um diesen scheinbaren Widerspruch und
diese verzwickte Geschichte verstehen zu
lernen ihr werdet sehen dass wir auf dem
Weg dorthin noch so manche Überraschung
erleben werden also auf geht's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Bulgarien ist laut den Berichten aus
Brüssel nicht nur das ärmste und
korrupteste Land in der gesamten
Europäischen Union sondern
wahrscheinlich auch das Pro russische
zumindest was die Meinung der Leute auf
der Straße angeht Ungarn liegt aber
nicht weit dahinter man könnte sagen
dass Sofia Jena geopolitischer
Großwetterlage entweder mehr in Richtung
Brüssel schwenkt oder in Richtung Moskau
zumindest war das noch bis vor kurzem so
deshalb betrachten viele Analysten der
internationale Politik dieses Land als
eine Achillesferse der Europäischen
Union und sehen es auch als Trojanisches
Pferd in der NATO die Frage die uns alle
stellen sollten lautet also wie um alles
in der Welt passt das alles zusammen
keine Angst wir werden das alles klären
aber zuerst müssen wir uns ansehen woher
eigentlich diese Vorliebe für Russland
kommt
die Tatsache dass so viele Bulgaren eine
positive Meinung zu Russland haben hat
einige logische Gründe und einer der
wichtigsten davon ist paradoxerweise ein
historischer Grund vulgarien hat eine
gemeinsame Geschichte mit Russland wir
müssen bis in die zweite Hälfte des 18
Jahrhunderts zurückgehen als der
russische Zahl Alexander der zweite
maßgeblich an der Befreiung der
bulgarischen Nation vom Osmanischen
Reich beteiligt war ihm es sogar eine
Reiterdenkmal im Herzen der bulgarischen
Hauptstadt Sofia gewidmet das den Namen
trägt Denkmal des befreierzahlen und
tatsächlich nur die russische Hilfe
ermöglichte später die Gründung eines
unabhängigen bulgarischen Staates aus
diesem Grund waren die Beziehungen
zwischen Bulgarien und Russland nicht
nur historisch gut sondern es wurde auch
lange Zeit eine positive Sichtweise
kultiviert die so weit geht das Russland
eben als ein großer befreiender
dargestellt wird tatsächlich benutzen
die Bulgaren nicht nur die kyrillische
Schrift sondern sie wollten auch der
Sowjetunion beitreten und obwohl sie
letztendlich nicht geschah handelte sich
in der Praxis um sowas wie die 16
sozialistische sowjet Republik
aber ja ich weiß was viele von euch
denken die ist verwirrt-union ist
kollabiert und ist etwas was im 19
Jahrhundert passiert ist wirklich so
wichtig für die Gestaltung der
internationalen Beziehungen im Jahr 2023
nun in der Tat können wir in diesem Fall
sagen eindeutig ja und die traditionelle
bulgarische Sichtweise auf Russland
steckt nicht nur in den Köpfen der
Menschen nein sie spiegelt sich deutlich
in der Innenpolitik des Landes wieder
um euch einen Eindruck zu verschaffen
von den 28 Parteien und Koalitionen die
bei den Wahlen im Oktober 2022
kandidierten waren etwa 15 dem Gremmel
gegenüber offen freundlich eingestellt
ganz genau besprechen über den Oktober
2022 ein halbes Jahr nach dem Angriff
Russlands auf die Ukraine und obwohl die
meisten dieser Parteien aufgrund der
starken politischen Zersplitterung in
diesem Land das mindestquoren von 4%
nicht erreichten kommt man zum Ergebnis
das ungefähr jeder vierte oder fünfte
bulgarete eindeutig Russo so viele
Parteien stimmen und das hatte
verständlicherweise einen großen
Einfluss auf ihre Aktion der Regierung
bezüglich der russischen Invasion gehabt
zumindest was die offizielle Reaktion
angeht
[Musik]
März 2022 während Bulgarien der Ukraine
humanitäre Hilfe leistet schickt es
keine Waffen wir befinden uns zu nah am
Konflikt um das zu tun sagte Petkov aber
was wäre wenn ich euch verraten würde
dass dies nichts weiter als eine Lüge
war um keinen Aufruhr in der
Landespolitik zu verursachen und was
werde ich euch sagen würde dass die
Regierung es geschafft hat diese Lüge
fast ein ganzes Jahr lang bis in den
Januar 2023 hinein am Leben zu halten
während Sie insgeheim die ganze Zeit das
genaue Gegenteiltag hat es stellte sich
nämlich heraus dass der frühere
bulgarische Ministerpräsident Koff das
eine gesagt und genau das Gegenteil
getan hat selbst wenn dies bedeutet die
Wahrheit vor den Mitgliedern der eigenen
Koalitionsregierung und natürlich der
bulgarischen Bevölkerung zu verbergen ja
es ist genau das was geschehen ist zu
Beginn der Invasion spielte petkosten
nämlich eine Schlüsselrolle bei der
Rettung der Ukraine das haben die
Recherchen der deutschen Zeitung die
Welt ans Licht gebracht und die Frage
ist nun was genau hat Bulgarien zu
Beginn der Invasion getan und was waren
die Folgen für das Land und die
Regierung Petkov wieso war einer der
wichtigsten Retter der Ukraine und wie
ist das alles ausgegangen all diese
Fragen werden wir heute natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einem
kleinen werbeshinweis unseres Sponsors
nordpass zum Thema Passwortsicherheit
etwas was viele leider noch immer auf
die leichte Schulter nehmen dabei kann
ein sicherer Umgang mit Passwörtern und
wirklich einfach sein wenn man nur einen
guten Passwort Manager wie nordpass
verwendet denk mal darüber nach wie
viele Benutzernamen und Passwörter du
plötzlich erstellt hast für Webseiten
Apps E-Mail-Accounts und so weiter
mittlerweile hast du vermutlich eine
beträchtliche Zahl an Passwörtern für
all diese Dienste angehäuft oder hast du
etwa dasselbe Passwort mehrfach
verwendet Okay geben wir es zu das haben
wir alle schon mal getan es ist nun mal
leider üblich aus Zeitmangel oder einer
Bequemlichkeit zu einfache oder
wiederkehrende Passwörter zu verwenden
das Problem ist solche Nachlässigkeiten
können wir uns immer weniger erlauben
ohne unsere Privatsphäre und Sicherheit
nicht zu gefährden allerdings kommt
jetzt die gute Nachricht mit nordpass
kannst du automatisch sichere Passwörter
für all Deine Kunden erstellen und sie
an einem zentralen ortspeichern ohne
dass du sie dir merken musst außerdem
erlaubt das Auto Phil Feature von
nordpass schnelles biometrisches
einloggen überall ohne Passwörter
eingeben zu müssen du kannst mit nur
einem Account bis zu sechs Geräte
verwenden und Notpass dort automatisch
für die Synchronisation deiner
Login-Daten nordpass bietet aber noch
mehr nämlich proaktiven Schuster der
Daten durch verschiedene
Sicherheitsfunktionen nordpass Premium
durchsucht das Internet nach deinen
Daten und dann krieg falls sie gelegt
wurden so kannst Du rechtzeitig handeln
bevor größere Schäden entstehen und das
Beste für die visualpolitik und die gibt
es als besondere Aktion einen Monat
gratis wenn du den Link in der
Videobeschreibung benutzt oder den Code
visualpolitik.de du kannst dort passt
außerdem risikofrei testen da ist eine
30-tägige Geld zurück Garantie gibt aber
ich bin mir sicher dass du es auch
danach nicht mehr wissen willst und
falls Du uns nicht mehr messen willst
kannst du unsere Arbeit auch direkt
durch eine Spende unterstützen den Link
dazu habe ich euch ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung unter dieses Video gepackt
wir danken an dieser Stelle herzlichst
allen unseren Spendern ihr seid wirklich
die Besten aber nun wieder zur
Beantwortung unserer spannenden Fragen
wieso war vulgariens per Post ein wahrer
Retter der Ukraine und wie ist das alles
für ihn und Bulgarien ausgegangen
aufgepasst
[Musik]
der Mann der für die Ukraine gelogen hat
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
hat die mehr oder weniger ausgewogenen
Beziehungen zwischen Russland und vielen
der osteuropäischen Länder zerstört
infolgedessen befand sich auch Bulgarien
ein eher pro russisches Land plötzlich
an einem Scheideweg die Wahrheit ist das
Bulgarien traditionell sehr abhängig von
Russland ist und vor allem das wird
jetzt wahrscheinlich niemanden
überraschen wenn es um die
Energieversorgung geht nicht weniger als
95% der 3 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas die
das Land jedes Jahr verbraucht wurden
von Russland geliefert und praktisch
dasselbe galt für Öl wir reden hier also
defacto von einem russischen Monopol auf
dem nationalen Markt Bulgariens zur
Beginn des Krieges standen 60% des von
den Bulgaren verbrauchten und wurden in
einer Anlage der Firma look-oil in
Burgas einer Stadt an der bulgarischen
Schwarzmeerküste raffiniert doch trotz
dieser kompromittierenden Situation und
der politischen Probleme die sie ihm
bereiten könnte bliebt patkopf nicht
untätig und schafft es sein Land zum
ersten in der Europäischen Union zu
machen dass die russischen Gasimporte
vollständig abstellte gut gerade nach
dem Gastraum die Lieferungen im April
2022 eingestellt hat was das Öl angeht
ist dies bisher allerdings nicht
gelungen
Bulgarien ist bis Ende 2024 vom
russischen Öl embargo ausgenommen aber
wartet ein Moment in der wichtige Teil
dieser Geschichte ist nicht das was wir
schon wussten sein das was wir bisher
nicht wussten die bulgarische Regierung
oder besser gesagt Kopf und seine
vertrauenswürdigen Minister nutzten
diese Ausnahmeregelung teilweise aus um
ihr Land zu einer Brücke für die
Lieferung von Diesel in die Ukraine zu
machen vor allem zu Beginn des Konflikts
und jetzt kommt dieses Diesel wurde vor
allem für die Versorgung von Kampf
Fahrzeugen verwendet sie taten dies als
Antwort auf eine spezielle Anfrage der
ukrainischen Regierung an die
bulgarischen Behörden aber die Frage die
sich viele von euch vielleicht stellen
ist wenn die Raffinerie in Bulgarien
lukull gehört einem großen russischen
Ölkonzern wie konnte die Russen dazu
bringen diese in das Land zu exportieren
gegen dass sie in den Krieg gezogen sind
nun um dies zu vergessen wurde offenbar
eine große täuschungsaktion inszeniert
viele der Mitarbeiter der Look
eureraffinerie in Bulgarien waren gegen
den Krieg und stimmten zu der Anfrage
nachzukommen konkret benötigt Bulgarien
etwa 50% der diesel-produktion dieser
Raffinerie für den inhaltsverbrauch der
Überschuss geht fast ausschließlich in
die Ukraine wir sprechen von wörtliche
rauen Mengen die zwischen Januar und
November 2022 in die Ukraine exportiert
worden insgesamt ging es um Treibstoff
im Wert von 1900 Millionen Euro 1000 mal
mehr als im Vorjahr 2021
[Musik]
das alles geschafft ohne dass die
Öffentlichkeit davon wusste und
paradoxerweise mit russischen Öl ja ihr
habt euch nicht verhört dass Diesel das
über Bulgarien in die Ukraine gelangte
wurde von look-oil aus Öl raffiniert das
aus Russland kam und dann wurde es über
Rumänien in Zügen und Tanklastern in das
Nachbarland geschafft um die ukrainische
Kriegsmaschine Laufen zu halten
insgesamt hat Bulgarien mit dieser
überraschende Methode bis zu 40% des
gesamten von der Ukraine benötigten
Diesels abgedeckt das heißt ohne diese
List hätte die Regierung selenski zu
Beginn des Krieges noch wesentlich mehr
Schwierigkeiten gehabt den russischen
Ansturm zu widerstehen
aber das ist noch nicht alles der
vielleicht interessanteste Teil von
petkovs kleiner Lüge ist das Bulgarien
keine Waffen geschickt hat heute wissen
wir das auch das nicht ganz richtig war
es hat sich herausgestellt dass
Bulgarien zu Beginn der Invasion eine
Menge Artillerie Munition an die Ukraine
geliefert hat sagen wir einfach dass sie
die Tatsache ausgenutzt haben dass die
bulgarische Armee größtenteils mit der
gleichen sowjetischen Ausrüstung
ausgestattet ist wie die Ukraine und mit
welchen Husarenstück haben sie das
wieder angestellt nun konkret hat die
Regierung große Mengen an Munition für
ukrainische gerade mehrfach
Raketenwerfer Übertritt wenn man mit
Sitz in Ländern die Polen oder
Tschechien in die Ukraine geliefert okay
es gibt Leute die Munition nicht als
Waffen betrachten aber Tatsache ist das
dies nun mal die Lieferung von
Rüstungsgütern darstellt also ja Kiri
Petkov hat auch in diesem Punkt gelogen
und der Ukraine zu helfen
weniger klar ist inwieweit er ist
tatsächlich geschafft hat dies alles im
Geheimen zu tun in dem April 2020
erfuhren wir diese
setzt Lieferungen an Polen und Bulgarien
aus Zufall nun keine Ahnung ohne
Kenntnis der Firmeninterna können wir
nicht wissen ob die Reaktion von
Russlands Gazprom direkt mit der
bulgarischen Hilfe für die Ukraine
zusammenhängt aber sie ist schon
ziemlich auffällig das erstaunlich an
dieser ganzen Geschichte ist auf jeden
Fall wie die bulgarische Regierung oder
zumindest ein Teil der Regierung die
Ukraine heimlich unterstützt hat
tollerweise Munition und russischen
Treibstoff an die Ukraine zu liefern das
ist schon ein starkes Stück da stellt
sich natürlich die Frage ob dieses große
Geheimnis nicht auch ein großes Problem
dargestellt hat ich meine welches andere
Motiv außer der Angst dass die Energie
Reserven ausgehen könnte Kopf gehabt
haben um zu diesem Zeitpunkt zu heimlich
zu handeln klingt es nicht seltsam dass
ein Naturland praktisch im Verborgenen
manipulieren musste während viele andere
lautstark ihre Unterstützung bekundeten
und die großen Geschütze auffuhren und
keine Angst das alles werden wir jetzt
sofort aufklären
ein Land am Scheideweg
wie ich schon zu Beginn des Videos
erwähnt habe ist die politische
Situation in Bulgarien nicht gerade
sagen wir mal rosig festgefahrene
Regierungen alle paar Monate Neuwahlen
in effektive Regierungskoalitionen die
Lage in Sofia ist so angespannt dass
jeder falsche Schritt der nur ein paar
Regierungspartner verärgern könnte dazu
führen kann dass das Ganze Kabinett
explodiert und Neuwahlen ausgerufen
werden ein Beispiel für all das ist die
Regierung von Kopf die nur etwas mehr
als ein halbes Jahr von dezember 2021
bis August 2022 Bestand hatte im
Gegensatz zu dem was ich viele von euch
sicherlich vorstellen hatte das Ende
dieser Regierung jedoch nicht wirklich
etwas mit der Ukraine Frage zu tun der
Stein des Anstoßes waren viele mehr
Meinungsverschiedenheiten über den
Haushalt und Bulgarien Position zum
Beitritt nordmazedoniens zur
Europäischen Union naja wir haben ja
bereits erwähnt dass in diesem Land
immer irgendwas los ist die Sache ist
die das zum Zeitpunkt des Drehs dieses
Videos Bulgarien nur einen
geschäftsführenden übergangsminister
Präsidenten hat namens galaponet
dieser Herr ist ein unabhängiger
Kandidat war bereits in zwei vorherigen
Regierungen Minister und ist jetzt noch
bis zu den nächsten Wahlen im April 2023
wie gesagt geschäftsführender
übergangsministerpräsident aber ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob wir uns das jetzt
nun wirklich merken müssen denn um zum
Thema petkovs Geheimhaltung und Lügen
zurückzukommen müssen wir ein paar
andere Dinge beachten erstens stand Kiel
Petkov an der Spitze einer sowieso schon
wackeligen Regierung die sich aus
sozioliberalen Zentristen pro westlichen
konservativen und eine links Koalition
Unterführung der bulgarischen
Sozialistischen Partei zusammensetzte
für diejenigen unter euch die nichts
über die bulgarische Politik wissen und
das ist vermutlich die große Mehrheit
die bulgarische Sozialistische Partei
ist der direkte Nachfolger der
bulgarischen Kommunistischen Partei und
hat sich in den letzten Jahren immer
mehr auf raus so viele und sozialen
konservative Position zu bewegt Beispiel
gefährlich nun sind oftmals das folgende
an die bulgarische Sozialistische Partei
ist gegen die Verlängerung der Sanktion
gegen Russland weil sie den bulgarischen
kommunalen interessenschaden der
bulgarischen Wirtschaft der
Landwirtschaft und dem Tourismus der
springende Punkt ist nur hätten alle
Länder die durch die Sanktionen etwas zu
verlieren hatten nur an sich selbst
gedacht wäre keine Einigung zustande
gekommen und Putin wäre mit seinem
perfiden Plan glatt durchgekommen und
tatsache ist dass diese Partei mit vier
Ministerien in der Regierung nicht
gerade die beste Voraussetzung dafür war
um Russland gegenüber hart
durchzugreifen oder überhaupt etwas zu
unternehmen aber natürlich war die
Meinung auf der Straße auch nicht gerade
hilfreich
im Allgemeinen ist die politische Klasse
Bulgariens zumindest die großen Parteien
mit regierungsoptionen eher pro westlich
eingestellt ebenso wie die
wirtschaftlichen Eliten des Landes und
sei es nur wegen des stetigen Stroms von
Millionen von Euro der dank der EU-Fonds
nach Bulgarien fließt er der die für die
lokalen Teil Kunst zu einer echten
Goldgrube gewonnen sind
[Musik]
für die normalen Bürger sieht die
Situation jedoch etwas anders aus ein
großer Teil der Bevölkerung konsumiert
häufig russische Propaganda und einige
Medien werden direkt von Moskau
kontrolliert und das bedeutet das der
Kreml weiterhin großen Einfluss auf die
öffentliche Meinung in Bulgarien besitzt
wenn es ein Land gibt in dem sich die
russischen Propaganda Agenturen und die
desinformationsstrategen des Krems
wohlfühlen dann ist es laut Analysten
und international Organisationen aller
Art genau Bulgarien Russland
Informationskrieg weitet sich auf
Osteuropa aus der Kreml bezahlte in
Bulgarien Journalisten politische
Analysten und andere einflussreiche
Bürger mit 2000 € pro Monat damit sie
pro russische Inhalte online stellen
Forscher haben außerdem ausgeklügelte
Netzwerke von Fake Accounts und Trollen
aufgedeckt die für eine zunehmende
Verbreitung von Desinformation
Propaganda im Land sorgen und glaubt
mehr Bulgarien ist da wahrlich keine
Ausnahme es war dort nur leichter das
Netzwerk aufzudecken die für Putin
hochgradig attraktiven Ziele Deutschland
Österreich und die Schweiz dürften
logischerweise auch ganz vorne mit dabei
sein wenn es um öffentliche
Meinungsbildner geht jedes profits gegen
ihr eigenes Volk den Krem gegenüber zu
knechten wagen wir können täglich auf
sie treffen hier auf Youtube in der
Presse wie auch im Fernsehen eine
früheren Videos haben wir bereits über
die Rolle informationskriegsführung im
Rahmen der hybriden Kriegsführung
gesprochen die Russland typischerweise
in seinen internationalen Beziehungen
anwendet
das Ergebnis ist wie auf dem Bildschirm
sehen könnt das Mitte Juni 2022 als die
russische Invasion bereits in vollem
Gange war und eine Reihe von
Kriegsverbrechen perfekt dokumentiert
waren nur knapp die Hälfte der Befragten
Bulgaren Russlands für den Einmarsch in
die Ukraine verantwortlich machte
schlimmer noch mehr als jeder vierte
glaubte dass der besten an den
Geschehnissen schuld sei indem er
Russland provoziert habe bedenkt bitte
dass wir über ein Land sprechen dass du
wohl Mitglieder NATO als auch der
Europäischen Union ist es kann sein dass
ich all dies im Laufe der Zeit und durch
die vielen russischen goldtaten ändern
wird aber das Problem ist da und es
hilft zu verstehen warum dieses Land auf
einem schmalen Graz zwischen dem Westen
und Russland wandelt und in der Tat hat
die derzeitige bulgarische Regierung
sehr seltsame Schritte unternommen die
für viele von euch schwer zu verstehen
sein durften es geht um Dinge die diese
22 November 2022 Bulgarien wird einer
schwarzmeeraffinerie die einem
russischen Ölkonzern gehört erlauben den
Betrieb vorzusetzen und bis Ende 2024
Ölprodukte in die Europäische Union zu
exportieren obwohl Brüssel davon waren
dass dies gegen die Funktion der EU
verstößt Schätzungen der Regierung in
Sophia zufolge wird der Deal zwischen
Bulgarien und dem russischen Unternehmen
Look all den bulgarischen Haushalt einen
zusätzlichen Schub von 350 Millionen
Euro geben obwohl Brüssel davon waren
dass dies gegen die Funktion der EU
verstößt mit anderen Worten es scheint
also wolle Bulgarien seine besondere
Ausnahmeregelung bezüglich der
russischen nutzen um Geschäfte zu machen
und russisches Öl in die Europäische
Union zu exportieren aber das meine
Lieben Zuschauer ist schon wieder ein
Thema für ein eigenes Video also Abo
nicht vergessen und bis dahin sind die
Fragen wieder an euch gerichtet was
haltet ihr davon dass der ehemalige
Ministerpräsident kaufte Ukraine
heimlich geholfen hat hat er seinem Volk
damit er geschadet oder er geholfen und
sind Länder die Bulgarien Ungarn
überhaupt zuverlässige naturverbündete
und EU-Mitglieder wie immer sind wir auf
eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja geht uns bitte ein Like teils
mit euren Freunden und diskutiert es mit
ihnen und vergesst bitte auch nicht das
Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen und keines
unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
vergesst bitte auch nicht das
unverbindliche Angebot unseres heutigen
Sponsors nordpass der für die
visualpolitik Community eine ganz
besondere Aktion bietet du bekommst
einen Monat kostenlose Nutzung wenn du
den Link in der Beschreibung unter
diesem Video benutzt natürlich freuen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch mit dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]